Kê hai mê chiến tháng năm, cơ quan cạnh sát đều tra công an thành phố Hàn Nội đã ra quyết định
hơi tổ vụ an hình dự. Hơi tổ bị cân đối với bốn đối tượng về hình vi sản xuất,
bốn bán hàng giả là lương thực thực phẩm. Trước đó, ngày 1 tháng năm,
phòng cạnh sát kinh tế công an thành phố phối hợp đổi quản lý thị trường số một kiểm tra cửa hàng gạo
tất kì, quận mắc tử liên. Phát hiện tâm trong 7.5 kg gạo giả nhấn hiệu ST-25
lùa tôn, đặc sản xóc trang của dân nghiệp tư nhân hồ quan sĩ. Chù cửa hàng, phát hiện an pết,
hai nhận đã bản bà với viến thị mình, chù cửa hàng gạo tại hình hoài đức,
để sự dụng lại gạo dẻ tiền đống vào bà bị giả nhấn hiệu gạo ông của nhằm chục lời.
Vọ bà bị được hai đối tượng mua tử lấy thị nhàn và vũ thị biết ngọt, người kinh xanh bà bị tại xả nước xa,
hình hoài đức. Hà m said hình cấp các định liền quan, lực lượng chức năng thu giữ vình bốn tấn gạo dùng để đón kóa ra,
hơn 3 mi tám nghiệp bà bị cùng nhiều thiết bị phục vụ đong cói.
Ý tính, nhau đối tượng đã bà ra thị trường khoảng 148 gạo ra.
Công ăn thình phố hạn nội tích tục mở giọt điều tra,
sử liên em theo quy định pháp lượt nhằm bà về quyền lời người thương dùng và sữ vũ thương giữ gạo việt.